There are a couple of answers that I think you could make arguments for, for
what might be the correct answer for this quiz.
One of the things you might say is that the right one is doing a better job
because it's fitting so many more data points, that it's easier to
describe the pattern in the data, because you just have more data and so
you're a little bit more certain that, for example, if you kept collecting data,
something weird wouldn't happen that would mess up your fit.
So that's one argument you could make.
Another argument you could make,
which I think is perfectly valid, is that they're about the same.
That, considering how much data you have for
each one, each one's doing a pretty reasonable job of fitting.
And look, the data's pretty comparable between the two of them.
It's just that the one on the right happens to have more data.
But then if the trend continued on the left,
then you would probably have the same fit.
The point is though that there isn't a huge difference between these two fits.
That they're both generally describing the patterns and the data appropriately.